I want to take a quick drive around the
city of Berlin I wanted to do it in
authentic way and this is Tina you've
agreed to help me and you've brought me
this car what is it that sets up on the
only car that you could have in East
Germany was at Rabanne yeah is it a hard
car to drive yeah I will show you what's
the bra okay
so gentlemen you okay Tina
very good look at these buttons when yes
okay windshield wiper that's adorable
something nasty it's I'm Misha what did
I say be honest what did I say vagina
something vagina something that's what I
meant to say first yeah you have to pull
it down right yes then what okay then
where we third beat go to neutral and
then pull this she's gonna get it back
to neutral
oh and then press down to get the third
yes exactly what happens when you want
to do reverse I think I would just
probably get out of the car and push it
back
okay what happened now you need to give
guess I could give gas this is a
performance anxiety for me you know what
that is
where man is with a beautiful woman and
he becomes a little nervous yeah
[Applause]
so far so good yeah
oh my god when today
the problem is it's not a very good car
for romance because if I was on a date
with you and it was going well and I
wanted to put my arm around you look I
can't that's very hard in this car to
get my arm around you
maybe we should concentrate on the car
again just shot down in the shittiest
car I've ever been in any low do you
think maybe a second date maybe we just
even like that alright nice to see you
nice to see you take you
[Music]
you